herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich bin hier gerade bei lucca in
der küche und luca ist auch neben ihr
denn die haben uns heute etwas neues
überlegt jetzt wahrscheinlich schon ein
paar male gesehen wir haben eine pizza
vorbereitet und werden die gleich
schneiden in stücke auf dem tisch
verteilt und probieren diese blind zu
finden
dabei hat max grad schon gesagt aber
dann trotzdem doppel dabei wir haben
eine pizza vorbereitet ist eine pizza
[Musik]
allerdings bezahlt werden was nicht 5
millionen euro von mir dafür dass wir
das macht nicht schreiben nicht werden
wie den weltkrieg hatte geld wenn du mir
geben wird schreibt auch in fünf wieder
deutsche das hier ist die pizza
schwarzer boden einfach gucken wir haben
auch schon mal lukas gemacht video
aufgenommen wo wir die pizza ohne händel
gegessen haben jeder eine hälfte wird es
mir wieder geholfen hätten ihr versteht
schon check das auch ab dass unsere
leute dann wollen wir mal die kids hat
hier heraus zeigt ja schwarz sie hat
einfach etwas noch eine machen
also wir müssen die pizza jetzt in
kleine stücke schneiden wir wollen ja
möglichst viele stücke suchen die groß
werden die stücke zu herr 3,27
quadratzentimeter jeweils sechs kleine
stücke finden von der pizza irgendwo auf
dem tisch verteilt sein können und glück
hast du lust anzufangen nein
nein nein nein denn macht seine
pizzastücke suchen muss wäre ich in der
kamera sein wenn ich suchen muss ich mag
sind dann kann man das beste land der
kamera stehen wenn ihr nicht mehr
kindergarten seite wo seid ihr name in
der schule weil wir nicht noch einmal
alle pizza strich ist das heißt jeder
muss 1 2 3 4 5 6 12 von diesem kleinen
stückchen hier ich halt wenn man den
finger unternehmen damit ihr seht die
sind schuld der kleinert mit meinem
finger kann ich schon schnell essen so
der iss geführt vorbereitet in zwei
hälften hat sich ja schon die augen zu
gebunden und ich werde jetzt anfangen
die pizzastücke überall auf dem gesamten
tisch zu verteilen
luca muss es schaffen alle zu finden ich
werde dann parallel die zeit stoppen
muss ich nach einem bestimmten also gab
ich auch so ding benutzen unterarm und
bedarf machen basteln oder das also mit
den fingern nie gedacht wobei man mit
händen greifen sagen also nur so gut wie
ihr seht ihr den tisch es ist alles
vorbereitet sie gar nix pizzastück
gelegenheit direkt vor deiner
bei gar keine sorge ich würde sagen
leute bereitet die stadt vor luca du
darfst anfangen die pizzastücke zu
suchen in 321 okay da das erste das
erste einen pizza hatten wir schon
gefunden sehr gut nur noch elf weitere
pizzastücke sind jetzt suchen gute
taktik ertastet hier alles akribisch ab
wenn er etwas übersieht die zweite stück
ist die snack wir sind bei 18 sekunden
und er hatte auch schon das nächste
pizzastück ohs war auf einmal nicht
schlecht geht hat jetzt auch nicht darum
dass man einfach schnell ist weil die
besser kann man das nur schaffen wenn
man wirklich bei das gut man also wenn
man schnell und gleichzeitig geil ist so
der seite von smart ist jetzt natürlich
auch vorteilhaft dass ich als zweiter
dran wenn du musst den gesamten tisch
abtasten und kannst du nicht alle vier
stücke finden okay wir sind gleich bei
einer minute und ist da noch was das war
ganz und der ecke wie das aussieht ok go
kart das nächste kürzer stück mein handy
kann es glaube ich wegschmeißen jetzt
okay
ja das ist überraschend und man sollte
mal sagen wie viele pizzastück ist noch
gibt könnte wir sind mal zwei minuten
jetzt die zwei minuten marke ist
erreicht
noch 12 auf den tisch was fast immer
gefasst man weiß nicht wie groß der
schritt ist es ist das was könnte es
nicht sehen worüber raum und die ränder
kommen jetzt natürlich das ist nicht
ganz einfach drei mini sind erreichten
100 flugzeuge bauen wir haben vorne auch
ex pizza gesoffen und gleich das ganze
stücke mond dann wird natürlich auch
stock geklickt drei minuten 30 euro
freuen und was ist jetzt auch hier mit
kaufen in den winzigen wahrscheinlich
haben wir sehen hier das heißt wie ich
verteile jetzt auch jeweils die
pizzastücke ein wenig freunde natürlich
wundert warum die sodalen gerade werden
gerade das sei abgenommen haben wir für
euch wo habe ich die pizza stufe hier
hingelegt das haben wir gemacht das
ganze schaffen wird das heißt ich will
sagen max ist ready ich bin für dich
geht's los in 32 einen halt 1,2 sich
quer
da ist das erste update er das erste das
kommt nicht so ich das hier mal so wurde
ich kombiniere quasi deine taktiken
woher aber wie ist noch nicht nebenbei
erstmal suche ich nur gefühlt ist der
tisch jetzt schon zu ende und ich habe
drei stücke gefunden
auf jeden fall hier das klassische abend
gelegt die stadt gelegt was du hast
dieses konzerne am grand c-max geht auf
die erste minute hierzu den waltroper ja
der richtige dafür
nein das schafft es bindet das ist neu
du bist zu nah dran war doch noch weil
der verteidigung geführt und ihr macht
ihm war ich wieder der stücke oder haben
noch nicht angefangen hat ist das
sowieso erstmal die interessante taktik
die maxi verfolgt jetzt die ganzen
messen können aber gut schauen wie es
weitergeht und ich so du hast noch nicht
alle stücke tatsächlich das ist sehr
sehr interessant vendetta kritik einem
die mutter hat mir schon essen schmeckte
wer die letzten stücken finden
obwohl wir sagen wir dass man so was
nicht darüber dass die über tisch machen
mit der hand machen die handballer
erklären möchte noch mal dass ramos und
sehen den fall leute ich werde die
stoffliche auf den boden legen macht hat
ja alle pizzastücke hier erst mal
gefunden
jetzt geht es ums essen wie spät 16 07
20 uhr in der rue aufnahme sind wir sind
dabei vier minuten 52 minuten 30 grad
oder vereine gute zeit um 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
pizza zu essen und ein rotes auto freuen
man muss allerdings dazu
jetzt siehst ja auch so sicher sein dass
du den nicht mehr gefunden hat ist auf
der seite 55 euro ab das ist schon ein
bisschen schummeln
da muss ich ehrlich zugeben bei mir war
es so dass du ich hatte ja die augen
verbunden und habe sogar ein stück nicht
mehr gefunden was ich hatte aber schauen
ich glaube dass ich das hier ein
bisschen zum verhängnis gekommen ist
dann solltest du das noch 20 sekunden
du musst es nur in den mund klingen ja
das ist ja das ist ja das ist wichtig
und der modus nicht zu der mond ist
nicht zu dass sieben sekunden
er muss nicht zu okay leute und genau
jetzt ist max der meiner zeit alle
kommen hier sieht man es mal gegangen
beide auch schon in einem flugzeug
gesessen also beide jeweils ein low carb
ist natürlich groß
und ich habe davor auch noch zu hause
was gegessen
zum glück ist dieses denken an der seite
ihres bruders da sieht man doch nicht an
halle also ja leute wenn das video euch
gefallen hat dann lasst sehr gern ein
paar check lukas video ab wie gesagt
haben wir auch einen pizza challenge
video gemacht bis dahin wir sehen uns
und macht's gut